astrazéneca presentó un nuevo estudio
para tratar de acallar las dudas la
compañía anglo sueca anunció este lunes
que su vacuna desarrollada con la
universidad de oxford es un 79 por
ciento efectiva después de un ensayo
desarrollado con más de 32 mil
voluntarios en chile perú y eeuu además
la inoculación es un 100% efectiva para
evitar enfermedades graves o críticas y
es apta para personas mayores de 65 años
estos resultados del ensayo en eeuu se
suman a los del ensayo de la universidad
de oxford así como a los datos que nos
muestran su aplicación en el mundo real
la vacuna es bien tolerada y altamente
efectiva contra la severidad del cob y
schneck en lake louise studies
astrazéneca tiene la autorización de más
de 50 países pero todavía no ha recibido
el ok de eeuu algo que se espera que
suceda en las próximas semanas por su
parte la unión europea después de que
sus principales economías cancelaron la
vacunación inicialmente por sospechas de
causar trombos entre sus efectos
secundarios podría empezar a fabricar
dosis de la solución en países bajos
desde abril según
la farmacéutica sin embargo todavía
existen dudas acerca de la vacuna este
lunes se supo que en españa' el 52% de
los ciudadanos creen que la inoculación
de astrazéneca es insegura y noruega
investiga un total de 6 muertes
ocurridas después de la aplicación de
las dosis
las dudas se extienden a otros países y
reciben como respuesta la vacunación de
líderes mundiales con el objetivo de
tranquilizar a la población